foreign
this is a ring camera
um there is the article basically is a
video reveal Stephen Crowder emotionally
abusing his wife in a statement Hillary
Crowder's family says she hid his
emotional abuse for a year for behavior
for years so
um In fairness because you know it pains
us obvious this pains us this hurts us
but as outstanding journalists we gotta
do it gotta report on the facts so
that's also [__] Toto so
so hard we told us so hard
I do a boundary
no no you just you just did it I drew a
boundary and abuses you were not taking
a car
I drew a boundary at abuse and control
okay because if you if you refuse to do
white food things then I will go pick up
the groceries what are wifely things she
seems really pregnant in this video I
want to point that out
like I don't know how many months along
she is but she's clearly pregnant she's
very pregnant
um and he's flipping out and all right
we'll break down as it goes but yeah
she's very pregnant seems they're
arguing because she didn't go get
groceries and it's like bruh I make
um
.005 of what you make for a living
Crowder and Royce makes
.006 what do you think
Kroger delivery bro bring the [__] right
to your house yeah boom it's all done
for you and I know I don't know how you
feel but if I was married and my wife
was pregnant okay fine look I don't like
women that are pregnant three months in
and they're already like oh I can't do
any it's like you're fine you can still
do things but she's clearly not three
months we're now at the where it starts
to become very burdensome on a woman to
be pregnant like you can't just I would
order Kroger wouldn't you just go like
yeah don't worry about it we'll just get
the stuff sent and we'll just I'll I'll
cook or whatever it's fine he's being a
[__] [__] and she's very pregnant
at this point we're twins I want to
point out with twins
so I'm sure that's just as pleasant yeah
so I mean again we're just seeing a
little little snippet here but let's
keep going
what did she say
what'd you say about the groceries sorry
I it's it's you refuse to do wifely
things okay I will go pick up the
groceries
I'd be happy to do the groceries there
are no grocery Stakes wood pallets my
grill
how do you
respect the men
I don't understand what that means
I'm a man
the other man you see the mother comes
back
I have no idea where this is going with
that part is what is that that's that to
me is maybe somebody in the chat can
maybe help here what what does that part
mean the other man you see what does
that mean
for sure how do you respect men
yes the other man you see the mother
comes back no
no no
don't do nothing
you're not taking the car okay Royce and
I had a discussion immediately about
this before the show what was the
concern
how do they not have two cars they have
a lot of money and as I pointed out he's
a
[__] control freak he is a psycho
only a psycho has that much money and
doesn't your wife doesn't have a car
I'll put it into perspective for you if
you were super mega Rich right
you would want your wife to have oh it's
a Bible quote sorry
okay fine it was anyway go ahead the car
thing if you were Mega rich and you know
your wife was pregnant
you what another car at the house right
even if she wasn't pregnant it would
just be hey we have the money we it
doesn't have to be a goddamn Aston
Martin but you would want her to have a
car in case there's a fire or a goddamn
home invasion or she has to whatever a
flood a [__] hurricane if you're out
of town you travel a lot you're only a
[__] like controlling paranoid
lunatic
doesn't want the wife to have a car when
he's not at home and that's what this is
that's why they're fighting over a car
because he doesn't want her leaving and
by the way yeah she's not cheating on
him and then we're using number one
she's not cheating because he said
himself when he did his little monologue
that it was not in Fidelity and it was
not any any physical abuse so trust this
every day yeah trust me if she was
cheating he would have said it was
cheating because it would bolster his
case for custody later which trust me he
wants because if not she's getting a lot
of money
respect
yeah
right what was that a threat I don't
she's I don't was that a threat no he's
I'm and by the way guys trust me
this is not just oh you're like just
like I I'm not seeing it we're watching
this is abusive it's weird like not
physically we know but this is weird
like I joke on the show oh you know I
treat women terribly I'm actually kind
of nice for the most part there's times
I'm not the nicest guy oh your child
who's pregnant I have never treat I've
never treated a non-pregnant woman this
way like I've never I've never gotten to
this level where it's like I would never
get in a circle like this over a car and
who's gonna go like I would be like it's
fine if you want to go or I'll go it's
not a big deal I don't care this
wouldn't be happening because if I had
this kind of money my wife would have a
her own car do what you want to do it I
don't have his money I would have three
cars let's be realistic there'd be my
daily driver she would have a daily
driving car and then I'd have like a
nice fun car I have like a fun car you
know yeah the one the one you only break
out like it's Sundays it doesn't even
leave the garage in the winter yeah
don't leave Sunday when it's not raining
in Spring and Summer
okay Stephen I can't
feel why can't you take an Uber though
that's okay that's we're taking Uber
like I can't
I can't I can't go to the gym I can't go
to my parents I can't call my friends I
can't go I can't be home you're gonna
take the car and leave me here what why
can't you do any of those things he's
insane this is Dennis Reynolds right
level of Babel like you know when Dennis
Reynolds starts being super insane
I'm not allowed to eat the seeds Dee I'm
not allowed
listen to me you want to walk out right
now listen to me I can't go to the gym I
can't go to my parents I can't call my
friends I can't go I can't be home
you're gonna take the car and leave me
here Hillary just think of how boxing
has made me now tell me that's not why
can't he leave if she leaves I I mean I
know the real I know what you're gonna
say you're but I'm trying to use a lot
let's say what's the logic let's say
we're doing his logic let's say we're
doing Crowder logic right which is he
wishes her [__] was an [__]
um D but that's just my guess but one of
my real thing is like my my thing with
crap what I don't get is like
first off really weird I can't see my
parents like you work with your dad you
see your dad every [__] day that
seems weird you have Daddy Issues
Stephen that's [__] been apparent I
can't go to the gym why not why is
Stephen Crowder the guy who is making so
much money he could turn down a 50
million dollar [__] contract not have
another vehicle you can't even get your
wife I don't know man a nice Escalade to
drive around or something that you could
drive your kids around with and then you
go driving around what I'm assuming you
want to be a Vespa like I'm not really
sure but I don't get this like this is
weird like you're gonna box me and I
can't leave you're Steven Crowder you
should have more than one vehicle this
is pretty [__] stupid
what do you need me to pick up I'll get
it I'll be back on and back no that
doesn't work either you'll be back when
you're back either
I I understand the difference the only
thing that can make this better if he
was drinking a Bud Light this is I'm
telling you man
I've observed [__] like this my whole
life I know what this is and for anybody
that's trying to downplay this or act
like oh you know this is this is an
abuse like somebody on Twitter said to
me well he's not beating her and he's
not cheating on her so that's better
than some people have it I'm like oh
okay so you have to literally just knock
a chick's [__] nose in or treat her
like dog [__] and cheat on her that's
the only forms of abuse out there no
this is you know when you hear if it was
your sister and the husband was talking
to her like this how would you react
would you be like this is fine no right
any human be like what the [__] yeah
imagine if it's your sister imagine if
it's your sister you'd be losing your
mind you'd be like how [__] dare you
don't talk to my sister that way you
piece of [__] we had to roll up on my
brother-in-law when I was a teenager it
was like five of us we had to roll up to
my sister's house and like drag that
dude outside so I mean yeah your family
doesn't like again this is all the
patterns of whenever you hear these
women that go like I was abused he was a
narcissist any gasoline and he did all
if they just learned all these buzzwords
right and 99 of them are full of [__]
and they just learned some buzzwords
this is what actually that those words
describe when you're actually like
gaslighting somebody and [__] with
them and being a narcissist and closing
them off from their family and friends
and not letting them have a car even
though you're making millions of dollars
like these are all little yeah and
that's abuse dude I'm sorry this is
abuse that's the thing and I think
people have a really big miscommune
misunderstanding because it's terrible
[__] women all women are liars as
long as you're not using your stomach
like her pregnant belly like a punching
bag you're not abusing her no bro that's
not [__] true we never said that the
reason we get mad at every woman that
that says that somebody's doing that is
because 90 of the time they're not and
then then what that does is the 10 of
the time when it's [__] real No One
Believes them that's what's really going
on here's my thing if this if if this
right now was just was just her on a
show telling the story
bet because we've defended Crowder in
the past by the way so let's also we're
here we wouldn't be believed we would be
like I don't believe you this is
[__] you're a woman what the [__]
why wouldn't he let you take the car
that sounds stupid but when you're
seeing it
you're like what the [__] what do you
mean you can't take the car now
somebody's saying in the chat that maybe
the reason is saying I can't do all
these things this might be it was during
the lockdown yeah after his surgery
after his surgery where he couldn't
drive and she was probably the one
driving him around
oh that makes sense that you know what
whoever said that in the chat that
actually I don't have a date on this but
that actually makes sense that does make
sense
um
um but still like she and then he tells
her get an Uber or whatever it's like
you get a [__] Uber what's the you
know what I mean this is still like a
classic like psychologically abusive
situation not to mention the fact he's
making a giant fight out of nothing yeah
and it's very apparent to me from
watching this video he enjoys
putting his wife in this emotional state
I've dated women that like that are like
that I'm sure you have too yeah you've
dated women that love to just start a
fight and go in a circle over nothing
and that's I know people who date women
like that and you're like dude she's
just doing this to get a rise out of you
how do you not see it and like you know
nine times out of ten it's ninety
percent of the time that is generally
not my personality it's I can have this
argument for about 30 seconds before I
go all right all right do what you want
here here's money get steaks don't get
steaks I don't give a [__] take the car
burn the car I don't want to do this
anymore here's what it says do whatever
you want and then 10 seconds the Xbox
beep turn on that's what would happen
that's pretty good go ahead whatever I
don't care and then you hear a door slam
you're like bye
and then you put that and you're like
yeah she's gone so all right let's go
okay we're doing a race in the lobby
let's go come on that's exactly that's
real life that's a real person that's
not an abusive psycho you're like fine
go whatever leave I don't care and she's
really cheating and you're like I don't
care go
nine months pregnant and cheating and
you're like I don't even care just let
me relax please I work really hard for
three days a week at the place I'm
exhausted
well my staff works really hard but I'm
there they're tired and it rubs off on
me trust me I wish some of them would
rub off on me
and he just stares off into the distance
and just says nothing quietly for a
while
his mind wanders wistfully to the other
things
[Music]
yeah they're they're saying they
narrowed it down says the kids were born
in August 2021 so this is about June or
July probably
all right that makes sense that lines up
okay so now with with Saint what he's
saying is the only way out of this is
discipline and discipline
dude this that these words are weird but
here's the thing with crowd talks to his
wife like he's the leader of Nexium he's
you know what I mean but the thing was
with Crowder and that we've been there
I'm I'm [__] taking another shot here
because we're [__] right about him
all the time
he's not even this person this whole
like I'm the man of this household I'm
the one I'm basically 1950s Mad Men of
that see he he's not even really that
person no he's LARPing in his own house
in his own mind in his own body because
what he wants to be is is is one of the
Mad Men but he really is he's mad that
men won't come on him more and and
that's how
and he's bringing and he's just inherent
rage inside something about you is
burning and I don't know what it is some
say it's a god-sized hole yours is
probably a [__] sized hole and it's it's
it's you are so angry that you are not
the thing that you cosplay as every day
when you sit in front of no matter how
many cigars you hold or how many guns
you have on your desk or how many
shoulder holder has or how many times
you do deadly you dead lift the [__]
gay away You're sat on the inside and
what you're doing is you're pretending
you're something you're [__] not
you're a phony you're not like this
Crowder we had you from day one day
[__] one you're a phony alpha male
everybody but he knows it no one's
afraid of you yeah nobody's afraid of
you
um somebody in the chat pointed out too
that uh
uh that he's um somebody was pointing
out he never talks about his mom I don't
think he has daddy issues he has mommy
issues you think that's mommy issues
because he never talks about her that's
true everyone knows about Crowder's dad
I will say the only thing this video is
missing that would maybe help Crowder
out a little bit is if this woman had a
brother that could come under some blue
collar construction worker that could
just punch him right in this [__]
face like just level I'm gonna punch him
right in his chest where he got the
surgery
right in your [__] chest just but
could you imagine a brother fella
imagine there's another ring video where
he's like the [__] you say to my sister
hey Jessica boom I would that would be
the greatest payoff ever in this video
of a brother who's punched him in the
face and like good
Revenue
give up what she's just trying to
easily I know if I was trying to [__]
go and do something to someone I don't
care who it was letting me I'd be
[__] pissed you know this is such
controlling psycho Behavior I oh God
you should
watch it watch it watch it what is that
I love you with your abusive sick watch
it what does that even mean
or what like the answer is the answer to
why there whenever somebody tells you
watch it your answer should always be or
what
uh God what was the oh if you want leave
it alone yeah the officer leave it oh
there's some things about you leave it
alone
can you watch it oh
we got a Crowder
that is
bro for Stephen Crowder to let out an
F-bomb oh we're getting to see a little
bit of the dark side of the crowded
I don't think I've ever heard him say
[__]
wasn't that jarring
you know I wish I had the drop because
after he said that I was gonna go
pompanano now
wasn't that [__] that was [__] weird
huh
weird way to talk to the mother of your
children
watch it
and watch it
space we need to do something maybe for
a little bit okay I love you
I love you very much
I don't love that big brother oh
he is gonna get oh he's done
you're done buddy I mean you're always
gonna be around I don't love you you're
you this is gonna hurt you really by the
way we already pinned Crowder down so
I'm very confident in saying this when
he says I don't love you and then he
said this by the way anyone who's ever
done that commercial says those people
like this these are these manipulation
techniques mean nothing to me this is
like watching Matrix code because I know
what's really happening here yeah let me
translate let me translate what's really
happening here watch I'll tell you this
you need to I need some space she says
okay right okay he says he says I love
you okay I love you
I love you very much I love you very
much I don't love you I've never
received love from you when Crowder says
let me translate Crowder for you when
Crowder says I never receive love from
you that's not what he means what
Crowder actually means because of course
you why would you impregnate this woman
and have a second child not a second
child with this woman if you didn't love
her you it's one of their twins sorry
you're right why would you have any why
would you been pregnant when I have
children this one if you don't love her
that's Fairfax regular twins but that's
fine but but he's not he's saying you
love her why and but now notices his his
requirements for love
I she says I love you and then he goes I
don't love you and that's the problem
because you don't show me any love when
somebody like Crowder says you don't
show me any love let me translate some
sociopath for you what he means is you
are not as subservient to me as I would
enjoy what I consider showing me love
isn't raising my children or being a
good wife maybe she's not I'm not saying
she is maybe she is maybe she isn't I'm
not defending because I wasn't in that
house but what I am saying is when she
says that it's like she wasn't being
the way exact she wasn't treating him
the way producers treats him which are
walking on eggshells being very careful
whatever Crowder needs come and rub my
feet and she wasn't doing it in a timely
manner that is what he perceives as love
well not only that it says so because
he's now saying when I tell you you need
to do a b c and d you don't do exactly
what I say all the time that's not love
there buddy that's a [__] cult member
but I do like the fact that he's
literally do this is just I feel like
this is like you said I see right
through it because I feel like Bane it's
like right you merely adopted
narcissistic emotional abuse I was born
and it's I was molded by it
wait wait say that again I so that's
exactly what I said I need you to do
like you said a b c and d and she says
no and then he goes then you don't love
me yeah how's that different than if I
swear to God if you don't if you leave
me I'll kill myself that's essentially
when I go look I need an a b c d
ude
no I love you more than life itself okay
[Music]
yeah he says a little bit later put on
some gloves and pick up like trash in
the back is what you're saying but her
his definition of Love is her being
subservient notice the love is night you
show me you love me by sitting on the
couch and cuddling with me or rubbing my
shoulders when I'm doing work or making
me dinner or hear me out on this
birthing my twin children
birthing my twin children you know
that's a growing growing a human being
that's half my DNA inside of your belly
is pretty you know I don't know that's a
pretty big commitment
Hillary you're right right now
someone
dancing
worthy of a life worth no matter the
wife
Hillary Hillary come on now I'm not
gonna engage I'm not gonna engage
anymore I'm gonna go I'll get text me
what you need I'll get you the TV
I
I love you
I'm committed to you
I'm I'm not I'm not gonna do those
things you're not committed to anything
you're not committed to anything
you just said I love you oh he won't let
it go bro I'm telling you this
everything we said four years ago
everything we said four years ago and
everyone in you [__] in the comments
that were sucking Crowders dicks and
buying his chinese-made mugs and look
seeing past every red flag in our
[__] comment section years ago going
oh you sound like leftists you're just
attacking crowded because you're jealous
I'm gonna psychoanalyze somebody I don't
even know well it sounds like we're
pretty [__] spot on four years ago
weren't we geez and by the way Crowder
when you wear that shirt that says fight
like hell that doesn't mean with your
wife
walk the dog's front
are you committed
are you committed enough to get the
medications
as the Crowder has inside Stephen gets
angry and anger by his own admission
screams I will [__] you up at his
pregnant wife Hillary who then flees the
home
so I guess there's a part two coming
back yet they're not doing they didn't
drop all this they're not dropping it
all in one shot they're gonna drag this
out well Steve you wanted to be in the
game
in the review of audio and video text
message Stephen Crowder repeatedly
admits that he has a volcanic temper
which we [__] called and has been
working through therapy to control it
however at one point in the middle of
the of the middle of the audio files
I reviewed Stephen uh
however at one point in one of the audio
files
I reviewed Stephen Crowder gets upset
because he is frustrated that he is not
getting enough credit for not having
lost his temper for months but as it he
can't promise he won't lose it again in
the future I'm just mad because you're
not giving me enough credit for not
losing my temper two people who works
and I'm frustrated and I'm not gonna
stop yelling because that'll mean I lost
the fight okay so I am very sorry I'm
going to shabooms two people who two
people who work for Stephen in the past
not two people
two people who have worked for Stephen
in the past say that he has created a
cult-like atmosphere in the workplace
and is intolerant of descent you're
either fully for him or you're his enemy
one former employee told me in a
conversation on Wednesday in an
interview uh on Michael malice podcast
Dave Landau who used to be co-slaughter
Crowder said that Stephen had surrounded
himself with Yes Men land out at about
Crowder he's become a bully and he
doesn't realize it this is again this is
now Landau saying it wait how were you
informed that there is a don't talk
light and what was your reaction
um
I was pissed a bit because I know my job
I I know that he talks a lot I know that
he's the star of the show I know when to
throw him what he needs to be thrown I
know when to sit back it's what I did
with Anthony for years it's what I did
next to Artie it's what I I it's what I
do I'm not trying to ever steamroll him
right it was just hey don't be
don't be funnier don't be and it's
that's the truth I mean it sounds
bitter but I knew it was true because I
was pulled aside and I said and it was
hey make sure if you're doing a rant or
like you guys are riffing he gets the
last word you
look Marsh and I are immersion I could
be [__] that's for [__] sure
we're very mean occasionally to people
and that's fine but never never
have I ever been like
listen virgin you piece of [__] [__]
if mercy and I don't get the last word
you're [__] done yeah never
right Fergie never
right Virgie
he's not here
what does that tell you uh last word
stop doing that
that would drive me nuts bro it's just
like really bro did that maybe he
doesn't want to talk over you so that
the show is called louder with Crowder
but not loudest with Crowder he wants to
that's about a seven but not at a ten
you can understand that well [__]
Alice is going to be on his enemies list
now too Stephen crowd his enemy Stephen
Curry Michael malice gives a flying
Stephen Crowder's video list looks like
the [__] list of Jericho at this
point it really does
is it it was all about the title and I
wasn't respecting it so there needed to
be a light and I had to make sure that
you know he he got the last thing so
even if I did have a funnier joke I
would just leave it out it was important
to for the fans to not hear it I always
felt that my job as a comedian was to
leave out the good one
that's I that's
that's I I I don't know I've never heard
of that to be honest I mean I don't feel
like that's a thing I don't I want
everybody that I ever do this is the
truth and Marshall I'll tell you this I
want everybody that's ever doing on a
show with us to be as [__] funny as
possible if I could say nothing for an
hour it's dope let me get a guess like
Alex Stein I just [__] Amy Alex maybe
one of the Alex's Alex's I just sit here
I put my feet up on the console and I'm
[__] let him go yeah I don't
understand what what that need actually
Anthony cumia did make a good point
about that he had uh
and he made that point he's like yeah
I'm lazy if you want to come in and just
kill for an hour [__] great it's on
my show I own the show so it's great and
also I gotta go Gotta Give me a credit
he did make me laugh because he was
interviewing Landau via zoom and uh
Garrett the producer kept throwing up
but don't talk like alarm thing over
Dave's face on the screen that's great
and he's like uh-uh Dave you can't up
shut up the don't talk buttons and I was
like that's